how are you doing today sir very good
thank you good to be here
again
uh i'm doing this is amateur hour this
is like the punk rock days of what i
used to do
right um okay so mommy door yeah exactly
so you we're at cinemacon
you are about to world premiere the
first footage from wick 4.
right so let's go with the with the
things that i can think about off the
top of my head what's the title
right now we're going with chapter four
still title work in progress so it's
good chance that it'll be john wick
chapter four or something
i think something's kind of catchy right
chapter four something right
is this a debate like where you have an
idea and like it has an idea and you're
just figuring it out even that that
that's simple it's just we what we do in
all of them we try to watch the movie we
get it to a place that we want we don't
come with the title first we watch the
movie get that little emotional vibe or
whatever we think thread and find a term
that best of uh best uh affirms what
we're trying to say and that's the title
uh what footage are you showing today is
it just a sizzle reel it's a it's a
little bit of a trailer and a signal um
it's got some a little bit of action a
little bit of character a little bit
some of the new casts that we have in
the movie and uh
just a little like hey
[ __ ] you we did something bigger
for because it's been pretty quiet about
in terms of like what the story line is
and all that stuff so what do you want
fans to know about the storyline and
what the film is about i think it's you
know chapter four is a good continuation
of all three previous films and it's got
a bit of a conclusion to it which is
great um we introduced a ton of new
characters that have a lot to say about
john wick
from his past and from obviously present
i think the most thing uh it's
you know brotherhood it's hope it's
you know what the life would really be
like as a bit of an existential crisis
with john and i think that's the fun
part
you you just mentioned like ending do
you envision this understanding but
there's a good conclusion to an
emotional threat that we've already had
got it um
got it you've been doing um
uh this is you know you've done four of
these now is it one of these things and
i've talked to you about all these other
things you have in development
yeah exactly so
when do you actually because film comes
out next summer i believe next month i
think march okay my bad uh you'd be good
if i did some research um do you
envision this as uh
are you already thinking about like what
you want to direct after
this one you know when you start
thinking about other projects like
there's still there's at least half a
dozen projects that were attached in the
valley that i think are fantastic love
them all love to do them all that's not
a that's not like no to another john
wick it's just you know how you space
out your schedule who's available the
casting that has there's a lot of
components that go into your scheduling
love to do those other shows but also
you know whatever it takes to work with
piano again and if again right now we'll
just
see the finish line so we're trying to
get through this one and if it expands
out from there like always happy to talk
about it yeah listen i if you made 10
john wick films i'd be the happiest
person on earth
yeah like believe me i'm not trying to
get you away from wick i'm just curious
uh yeah but
sometimes i think it's really good to
to do a winnick then go learn and
experiment otherwise and bring that
knowledge back to wic so it could be
good to take a little bit
the thing that i love about the wic
movies like all fans that each film has
action set pieces that are unlike any
other and all feature different types of
combat different weapons different
everything i'm sure you've pushed the
boundaries again on wik4
um what can you tease fans about some of
the action set pieces kayla's got some
new skill sets which is good
he's got some new props which are great
uh we were fortunate enough to land some
very interesting stunt teams from all
over the world and each stunned team
from the different countries the
japanese stunt team the french continue
here in some teams they all have a
little bit of flavor of motion i think
that helps change the set pieces as well
so when you get all these different
experts and different martial arts it
forces us to adapt the choreography to
show different things
one of the things on the first and i
could be wrong about this but i believe
in the first film or two you guys did a
lot of um specific
uh like a lot of training for specific
scenes and with three it was more in the
moment how was wick four
uh again we expand the skill sets we
dialed in on all the movements and then
we kind of mix and match and that asex
feels a little fresh they're all within
the same things it's like the chinese
menu theory you get all the sequences
done and then we mix up the sequences a
little bit so it feels a little bit more
organic
uh it's my life because i'm just about
out of time with you uh obviously you're
in the editing room right now uh how's
the edit going awesome and post is one
of our favorite ones like that's really
really peaceful you see a little details
and you get to play with the different
performances and then it's the music
thing and the sound thing and then you
can see on the big screen really comes
to life with all the gunshots and all
the music and looking
away so when they give you the
one-liners
you